what is going on everybody welcome to
another python with raspberry pi
robotics video here we're going to be
taking one step closer towards the
welcoming of our new robot overlords
anyway what we're going to be doing here
is creating a program to sense distance
using our new ultrasonic sensor
if you missed how we hooked it up check
out the previous video in the playlist
the link to that is in the description
so let's go ahead and get started so
first of all once you log into your pi
you'll just you'll find yourself here
let's go ahead and cd into our robotics
directory
once we're in there let's go ahead and
just make a new file and we're going to
call this
sensor so
sudo nano sensor dot pi
now we need to program our sensor script
so we're going to only need two imports
here one we're going to import uh
rpi.gpio as usual and we'll import that
as gpio
then we're going to need to import time
and time is going to be used for a
couple of different things one will be
literally as a wait time but then also
to measure the time between
the signals that we send so now what we
want to do
is we need to define our function and
i'm just going to call this function
distance
and then in distance we're only going to
have one parameter and i'm going to call
that measure and in here is where the
user can specify whether they want
centimeters or inches and i'm going to
set the default to be centimeters
so moving on with our function one two
three four
what we want to do now is we want to set
the mode for our pins so if you don't
know when you set the mode basically it
just it's whether or not you want to use
the gpio pin number or the actual like
pin number on the board so i like to use
the board number so we're going to say
gpio dot set mode
gpio dot all caps board
next up we need to start off our pins
and specify what they're going to be so
we need to do the two setups so
gpio.setup
and we hooked up pin 12 as our output
pin to the trigger so gpio.out
and then oops gpio.setup
pin 16
and this is going to be our echo pin and
that is a gpio dot
input pin
and that's pretty much all we need to
set up so now we'll come over here
and we want to
make sure the gpi output before we start
doing anything just in case it already
had a value let's make sure it doesn't
have a value and we're going to say
gpio
die
output
12
false
just to make sure
now after we've done that we're positive
what we're going to say
basically what we do is we're going to
listen on our input pin which is 16
and as long as there is no signal
then
if it if there's no signal or it's false
we're going to take the timestamp so
what we'll do is wow gpio dot input
um whoops
while gpio.input
16
equals zero so it's false basically one
two three four five six seven eight
we're gonna say no sig
equals time dot time
so while that's the case no signal is
time.time and as soon as it is the case
2.4
wow gpio.input
16
equals one one two three four five six
seven eight
sig for signal equals time dot time so
now we're gonna have two time stamps
one's gonna be signal and the other
one's gonna be no signal
so then what we'll do is come down here
one two three four tl for time length
equals sig
minus
no sick so that's going to be how much
time went by
now we can calculate the distance using
because
we know the speed of sound is a constant
so we can use that to calculate actual
distance so
uh to do that though we do we did
specify the measurement so we're gonna
ask the question if measure
equals
cm
then the following calculation is used
one two three four five six seven eight
then the distance will equal
tl divided by
zero point
zero zero zero zero so four zeros five
eight
and now we'll return distance in
centimeters
next one two three four l if measure
equals
i n for inches
then one two three four five six seven
eight
uh distance equals
tl
divided by
zero point one two three one four eight
so three zeros one four eight and that
will return us a distance in inches
else
in case the person is an idiot and
didn't write it right print we just want
to have it print out
improper choice of
measurement
in rcm
okay
and that's all we need to do for that
function oh well we want one more thing
one two three
uh if this is the case distance equals
none
now
what we want to do
is run a gpi.cleanup gpio.cleanup
and then finally we want to actually
have this function return whatever the
distance is
now that's just all we need for the
function
but let's go ahead and actually call
this function so let's just print
distance
distance
um
in centimeters
so let's exit that save yes good right
and now let's go ahead and do our
sudo python
sensor dot pi
and we get a return of five centimeters
which looks to be about correct i've
placed that box in front of
the sensor so what we can do now is we
can move the box closer
and we can run it again
and now we get 1.7 which is again
pretty accurate i would say and then
also just to show you guys
if we do like here let's say that's not
a totally straight box but let's run it
we get 5.89 also just for kicks let me
show you we'll run it one more time and
you each time you run it you might
actually get
a slightly different value so some
people might run
two or three of these just to see
and then average them together something
like that all right so we've got our
sensor working and now we're ready to
move on with the next part
so i'm going to continue on the next
part we'll actually
add some of this code to our robot car
and then we can actually start to make
our robot car autonomous in the sense
that if it gets too close to a wall it
will reverse maybe something like that
so anyways that's what you have to look
forward to thanks for watching if you
have any questions or comments feel free
to leave them below in the comment
section
and thank you for your support your
subscriptions until the next video